a crash that killed 20 people in New
York State last year has raised new
questions over the safety of modified
stretch limousines
unlike buses and other large vehicles
federal regulators have limited
oversight over limos those laws are left
up to states and cities CTM consumer
investigative correspondent and a Warner
shows why a growing number of people
think that's a problem Anna good morning
good morning most stretch limousines
begin their lives as regular sedans and
SUVs they're then cut in half and
extended to fit more passengers but
because they're custom built they aren't
required to undergo crash testing or
meet the same federal safety standards
as other vehicles and some families have
learned just how dangerous crashes
involving those limousines can be will
you tell me about your picture I was
told it was the very last picture ever
yeah that last picture of eight young
women together heading out for a
birthday celebration one summer day in
2015 it was supposed to be a fun day of
wine tasting on Long Island but their
stretch limousine was hit broadside by a
truck after the driver of the limo made
a u-turn and the ending to this day is
just it's worse than our movie Nancy de
Monte's 25 year old daughter Joelle
sustained serious injuries as did three
other passengers the other four women
were killed including Paul Shulman's 23
year old daughter Brittany it's been
nothing but hell since people say time
heals wounds how do you go around life
and people think things get better when
you lose a piece of you that you never
get back just two years later in 2018
came the limousine accident in Schoharie
New York that claimed 20 lives it's not
just one state limousine safety
standards vary widely across the country
injuries gonna happen if it's not built
right if it's not built right Dave
Lipsky inspects stretch limousines for
the New York Department of
Transportation
he says lacking
tighter regulations custom builders
sometimes cut corners prioritizing
luxury over safety so what they would do
is put a beautiful bar and they have
beautiful seating and all the amenities
to have the niceness and put the
weakness in the infrastructure so in
other words they're adding the luxury
features but then in some cases they're
skimping on the safety measure correct
for example he showed us this crash bar
installed in a stretch limo brought into
his shop for inspection you see that
little thing there this round tube right
here so how it is so nice and teeny it's
supposed to protect passengers in the
event of a crash but you see how I can
bend this with my hand yeah I literally
can take this I can move it so a car
hitting the side of that is that that's
not going to be any resistance at all is
it there's no resistance there the time
is to get with the problem and solve it
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer is
now calling on the National
Transportation Safety Board to put more
emphasis on major safety reforms
nationwide what is not happening now
that needs to happen they haven't made
it a priority it limos fall in between
the cracks you can make a limo in one
state and it drives in another state and
there's nothing that that second state
can do about it the safety of the limo
is no different in Montana Texas Florida
or New York so there should be one
standard in a statement to CBS News the
NTSB said it shares Senator Schumer's
concerns and has made safety
recommendations for limos this year
directing passengers to use seat belts
we're required by law and encouraging
the use of seat belts and head
restraints we're not required by law the
National limo Association says it's
committed to raising safety standards
and is prepared to support prudent and
consequential safety regulations all
right Anna Warren it makes you think a
little differently about those long
stretch I don't see that being is used
as much as they used to be back in the
day but when they are used they're
normally crammed with a lot of people
yeah and often a lot of kids okay we
have wedding season prom season and all
those things yes think about